غضب دفين لدى الايرانيين يستيقظ ثم ينطفئ
منذ 23 عاما ليس رضا بتحصيل حقهم وانما
بالقمع وتسيير اليات القتل في الشوارع
فالتسلسل الزمني للمظاهرات يعود لعام
1999 طلاب غاضبون اضراب تجار ومعلمين
تمديد برفع الضرائب وغلاء اسعار الوقود
والمواد الغذائيه
مظاهرات خرجت بالالاف ملات شوارع ايرانيه
عده واحيت امالا بضعه هتافات مناهضه
للحكومه ومطالبات باصلاح الاقتصاد وتحسين
الظروف المعيشيه
لكنها سرعان ما تعود ادراجها مع بدء عداد
القتله من المحتجين بالارتفاع القمع جداد
لكن سقف المطالب ارتفع لي طال المحظورات
فالاحتجاجات التي اعقبت مقتل مهسا اميني
بدات برفض القمع الاجتماعي ورفعت شعاره
اسقاط النظام والموت للديكتاتور
[تصفيق]
بعد شهرين اختفى ما كان يصب حتى الامس
القريب في خانه المحرمه صور رموز النظام
الايراني لقيه المصير نفسه تمزيق وحرق
طالخ منئي وسليماني حتى انها وصلت للخميني
الذي انتقلت النيران لمنزله بعد صوره ولم
تخفض النيران قبل وصولها الى قم وحوزتها
للقضاء على المشكله من اساسها وفق مختصين
بشان الايراني
باتت على ارتباط وثيق ببعضها في عقول
الايرانيين وما حمله اسقاط العمائم وتعليق
المشانق الرمزيه سواء ادله اضافيه على رفض
المنظومه بشكل كامل ودخول الاحتجاجات في
نفق لا عوده